Hey it's me, Destin. So, um...
We got a hairbrained idea and
we came to an art festival...
It's not really an art festival,
it's a festival, here in Alabama.
We've made art with bullets
and tried to sell it.
So this is what we've got.
We've got a bunch of art
that we've made with uh...
With bullet impacts.
And we tried to make the
manliest setup possible.
I know it's a rainbow, but I
made it, which makes it manly.
[Bang]
Oh, that was sweet, dude.
So so far we've had... how much success?
- Zero.
- Zero, but we're men.
- We're men.
- We also have a high speed camera.
[Briley] We're introducing the
public to high speed video.
Welcome to Smarter Every Day.
[Splash]
(Destin) Alright. So what we do is we
just capture the image, or video of her
popping a balloon and what we're
going to do is go back and play it.
It's kind of like a time
machine, only different, so...
Look at this, right here.
[Music]
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.